good morning believe nation today's
message is create a business you won't
sell over to you Evan Spiegel so I'm
asked one question most often why didn't
you sell your business it doesn't even
make money it's a fad you could be on a
boat right now
everybody loves boats what is wrong with
you and I'm now convinced that the
fastest way to figure out if you're
doing something that is truly important
to you is to find is to find someone who
will offer you a bunch of money to part
with it see the best thing is that no
matter whether or not you sell you will
learn something very valuable about
yourself if you sell you will know
immediately that it wasn't the right
dream anyways and if you don't sell
you're probably on to something maybe
you have the beginning of something
meaningful there's a lot of books out
there there's a lot of thought leaders
out there talking about how to sell a
business how to build a company to flip
it or to sell it and that is something
that I just fundamentally am not in
agreement with I think the work that
you're doing should be something that
you really absolutely believe in and
where you spend your time should be
about trying to make a meaningful impact
and not just trying to build something
off to sell it to somebody else and so
for those of you who are of that mindset
you're probably not going to enjoy this
video but I approach it like a
relationship you couldn't offer me
enough money to want to leave my wife to
go do something else
you couldn't offer me enough money to
want to sell my business to go do
something else if you paid me X millions
of dollars to sell it to you and then I
could never help entrepreneurs again you
know I wouldn't take that deal because I
love what I do I think at the core is
you have to find the thing that you love
doing stop looking for businesses just
to make you money
but that you can get lost in that become
a piece of you now if you grow and
evolve when your business doesn't grow
and evolve with you and that means you
stop loving it and you need to sell it
fine but the intent going in
is I want this to last forever because
you make different decisions because you
care more because you value the work
that you're doing in the process of
building something and by doing that you
create a company that inherently becomes
much more valuable that's the funny
thing that by pouring the love into it
really caring about the product and the
service and the processes you create
something that's much more valuable than
if you were building something just to
try to flip it and sell it to somebody
else so if you're at the early stages of
your business you're trying to grow it
to the next step I would highly
encourage you to buck those trends of
building a business to sell it and
instead think about what is something
that I can build that is truly deeply
meaningfully amazing and valuable to me
and the world and I could not imagine
giving up that I would do this even if I
wasn't getting paid to do it because I
love the work so much you find that and
that's we're gonna find your ultimate
paycheck your ultimate value your
ultimate contribution girlfriend success
your ultimate happiness and so the
question of the day today is are you in
the business now that you would not sell
I'm curious to find out leaving the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion finally wanna give a quick
shout out to Coach molestin thank you so
much for the love and in buying a copy
of my book and for hailing me a cab in
New York City when I couldn't get one
myself I appreciate the love those are
you watching you had a chance at a shout
out in the future video make sure to
pick up a copy of the book and email in
your seats to keep track thank you guys
so much for watching and have an amazing
day continue to believe or whatever your
one word is and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot event